Joel and Ethan it's nice to see you guys
welcome so many of your films use music
in such extraordinary ways and of course
t-bones here with you today I know you
guys worked with him many times but with
this film
it's about musicians and music obviously
what is it about this sort of time
period that that you focused on that you
found most appealing why this moment in
time right before Dylan's arrival well
you know partly because it is right
before about a you know it's the scene
Bob Dylan walked into he's not there yet
I think he showed up in New York in 1961
right because why why before Bob because
what would you do with Bob you know I
people have made movies about am i its
icons just aren't our thing and I we
wouldn't know where to start it was an
interesting community you know because
it was still a small town before it kind
of changed largely because of Dylan and
became a big commercial thing it was it
was it was its Van ronk described it it
was gay it kind of felt like a small
town and you know anytime you you want
to make a movie you want to want the
specificity you want you know you want
to know what the setting is kind of what
the community is just to make this story
you know real somehow is the Jim knowing
something about the setting is important
to us just for getting our minds around
thinking about his story
the Cohens I want to say this that if
any filmmaker in the world came to me
and said we want to make a film we don't
know who's going to do it but we want it
to be about a folk singer in 1960 and
he's going to do three or four-minute
songs and we're going to do it without
any guide tracks and we're gonna film it
all live I would have said you should
rethink this don't do it it's a mistake
but because it was the Cohens I thought
I said okay let's do it because when
they're good you know as we all know
they're good but what you may not know
is how lucky they are
is that right that's I mean that they
are lucky they're lucky and this is the
kind this is how lucky they are they
fell you know there was nobody it wasn't
like there were ten actors we were
choosing a Liu and Davis from we saw a
lot of singers hoping we could find
someone who could act and we heard some
incredible versions of hang me oh hang
me we saved a lot of them because they
were they were really great but at a
certain point we we thought you know
we're kind of kidding ourselves because
this guy's in every frame of the movie
and we really I mean there's certainly
singers who became movie stars but we
didn't find one so well we found one but
but he's an actor so we then and also we
were we were we were looking we were
looking for a bit of a different type
originally and it was kind of an
interesting lesson and keeping an open
mind about the the physicality because
even though it's not Dave Van ronk Dave
Van ronk was a big kind of bear like guy
and we were sort of thinking that and
anyway then we saw Oscar and the
character for you like just sort of
crafting that character and and kind of
not trying to get the keep the audience
to love you all the time well yeah he's
a he's a he's a guy that is not out
trying to ingratiate himself or you know
doesn't use traditional means of warmth
to who to connect to people so so yeah
so that was that that was definitely a
challenge to you know just you know not
not that he's cool and detached he
actually runs very hot but um but he's
he's kind of alienated himself to the
point where he's he's just disconnected
he's a stranger in a strange land you
know sometimes the loneliest you can
feels when you're in a crowd and I think
that's that's where he's at where it's
just nothing's connecting and and it
really it was very freeing I do not have
to you know beg anyone for sympathy yeah
you know and and the only time that he
does open up is when he when he shows
that uh when he when he plays his songs
a friend of mine sent me this poem
a bluebird by Charles Bukowski and I
remember that kind of state it was a
mantra for me and that poem starts
there's a bluebird in my heart that
wants to get out but I'm too tough for
him so I inhale cigarette smoke and I
pour whiskey on him and the [ __ ] and
the bartender's never know that he's in
there and and then you know it by the
end of the poem he says I only let him
out at night sometimes when everyone's
asleep and I say I know I know you're
still in there so that that was that's
what the music is for Lewin is his
Bluebird your character it seemed like
this must've been kind of fun to put
together did you pull on some specific
characters from music history to kind of
formulate the hair oh yeah yeah and
everybody thought it was a piece the
beard was a piece the hair was minded I
was the great Jerry Mulligan baritone
sax player had a very interesting
haircut that I've always admired through
the years and I wanted the cop that
that's the only thing I borrowed in the
walk is fantastic - I mean it's just
that's thank you ever it's long from the
lady from Shanghai yeah I slowed my way
through the picture you know I I just I
felt like I read it and I understood it
and I got it and you know they've been
my favorite filmmakers ever since
Raising Arizona blue my little kid mind
and and so I and the screaming behind
blue paint over here you know and so I
always I got that I felt I understood
that tone and I always loved it and you
know that just despair and absurdity
mixed together and and and also being a
musician as well knowing that that's the
story of and I'm not just a musician but
as an actor as well so many people I
mean there's incredibly talented people
that that just things don't fall their
way and that just creates a cycle
because that closes someone off and then
they're not open for that next possible
little opportunity and then that closes
them off even more and
and then bitterness sets in and and and
seeing that happen and so I I felt like
I got it and I felt like I was I was
ready for it
this one we like Oscars performances at
The Gaslight
especially its first performance it's a
specific problem we shot with the two
cameras which is a lot for us that's one
more than the norm it was like I was
like weird wow there's a lot of cameras
on this set because there's two because
we wanted a lot of coverage and because
you know we didn't want to have Oscar
have to do you know 60 takes of the song
30 was you know you know which he did I
mean you know he's not only a good
enough performer a consistent enough
performer that such that we could cut
between takes and use all the coverage
but you know that's again a specific
problem we wanted to shoot a whole song
and have especially for the first
performance a lot of coverage so we
could start as we did and kind of
widemouth keep it interesting
it seems really cold was it cold I'm
usually warm we know we have the
opposite problem which was these
magnolia trees on Sullivan Street
leafing out we were panicking no no no
leaves no green no leaves we were yeah
and shooting plates for the car stuff
the whole sort of design of the movie
was built around you know cold wintry
sort of gray skies and pear trees and
and it was unusually warm and we were
concerned about that first of all the
the films are funny they're they're
frightening they're terrifying like
especially you can see Jon's characters
every single character Jon's played in
one of their films is horrifying
wildly and wildly intelligent and deeply
comedic all at once and that's you know
that kind of that kind of detail what I
love about it is you know when they want
to shoot a performer the detailed you
can get out of her performance of seeing
a live performer perform is so much more
complex and detailed and then what you
can get virtually in post-production
through using all the technology we have
to virtually reproduce a performance the
Coens in this one it was a it was a show
about a musician so it was important we
get as much detail out of the times when
that musician was living which is the
time he lived when he played write the
rest of the time he was existing as soon
as he stopped creating his own future
zone in reality his own environment this
other reality comes crashing down on him
but you know what I love about the
Cumbre so every frame has history on it
that's what I love about it oh just in
the details and yeah every frame is
history it's not like everybody just put
the camera over there to get from here
to there there's a reason that you see
the intelligence and the history behind
every behind every frame